[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Everybody, no
matter where you come from,
has someone that
they care about.
We built an app that is
a peer-to-peer safety
network that allows people
to select companions
from their contact book to
watch them walk home safely.
And if they ever feel
nervous or unsafe,
they can notify you
within three taps.
When we chose Google Maps for
the foundation of our app,
it was something that
developers trusted,
but the consumer also trusted.
We want to build something that
changes the way people live
and improves their life.
SPEAKER 2: Methane is
a huge global threat
to all of our ecosystems
and our health.
It affects everything
we are and we do.
And so I feel really
compelled day to day
to get up and try to fix
the problem in the best,
most impactful way that I can.
What we've done is
put methane sensors
on a number of Street View
cars to map and measure methane
levels coming from
under city streets.
The maps that we've created,
with the help of the API,
have really made this
data visible in a way
that it's never been before.
SPEAKER 3: There's
nothing getting
you ready for being homeless.
All of a sudden, everything
that we take for granted
is taken away.
And we find ourselves basically
sleeping in the streets.
I think it's my duty, as
a person that's actually
lived the experience, to give
back and actually help others.
SPEAKER 4: In Australia, one
in 200 people are homeless,
but 80% of them have got
a smartphone of some kind.
So there's a
tremendous opportunity
to get information
into their hands.
The whole point
of our application
is to help our users find
their way to the services
that they need.
Using the Google Maps
API means that we
can give people the information
they need to make a decision.
SPEAKER 3: There's
no signpost saying,
this is where you get food,
this is where you get blankets.
It doesn't happen.
We're giving this
for somebody who's
still homeless to actually help
them to come forward and be
reconnected.
[MUSIC PLAYING]